you will always have people selling doom
it's lucrative it makes you sound
serious but they will be proved wrong hi
I'm Nicholas V with reason TV and today
we're talking with Ron Bailey he's our
longtime science correspondent and he's
got a fantastic new book I've called the
end of doom Ron thanks for talking to us
delighted to be with you what news are
you bringing in the end of doom
well I think three major points one is
the population world population is gonna
peak in this century and begin declining
around the middle of the century and be
probably back to the levels it was at
the beginning around 2000 second is
where the downside of a super cycle in
commodity prices during the last decade
or so everybody saw commodity prices
going up oil for example metals and food
and now they're beginning to decline
they peaked probably five years ago and
they're now down about 50 percent from
their highs and third climate change is
going to be a problem but we will have
the technologies to handle it is it a
good thing that population goes down I
mean obviously there's always been scare
monger saying I we're gonna be teeming
with people a silent green situation but
a lot of people now are saying now the
real problem is when we don't have
enough people look at Japan look at
countries that are depopulated well
actually my goal is to have people have
as many children as they want to have
and if population goes down a result as
a result of that which it will likely do
given the choices that people make when
they get richer and women and women have
become educated that's what's going to
happen I think that we'll also be able
to handle a lot of the problems of aging
so commodities are going down what what
is driving the decrease in commodity
prices whether its food or oil or
whatever well what happens is is this
it's a super cycle what happens is this
prices go up then people get the
incentive to develop new technologies to
make substitutions for the things that
are going up also they go and find new
sources for it so in the case of food
what happened is is farmers intensified
they didn't really expand them it's a
land of growing food on but they
intensify the amount of food they got
out of the land that they have surprises
are now going down and similarly
happening with oil is is that people as
the price began to go up people started
using less but also then
was more exploration and tracking was
invented and fracking has dramatically
increased well or not invented but just
it went mainstream right it it became
cost-effective and now climate change is
real it's happening they say it will be
manageable is that also based on
technology yes but first let's deal with
climate change by analysis I've been
covering this for a very long time I
changed my mind about it about ten years
ago is that the balance of the evidence
suggest that climate change could become
a significant problem by the end of the
century not definitely but it could be
therefore I think we should have some
insurance policy kind of attitude toward
it and one of the things that we're
doing is developing technologies that
we'll be able to reduce the amount of
fossil fuels we burn to produce energy
which will decrease the amount of
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere but
that's kind of down the road right
because all we already have enough I
mean even if we stopped all greenhouse
gas production now there's still
momentum right there is going to be some
warming but if it's below two degrees
centigrade which is like it's likely to
be I would argue it won't be a
significant problem but then there's the
question of how do you deal with the
actual so how do you deal with climate
change it's not simply by shutting it
down by not using greenhouse gases but
how do you deal with kind of that well
there's a whole bunch of different
things first you want to reduce the
amount of greenhouse gases ultimately
that end up in the atmosphere and we're
going to have wonderful technologies
some fabulous new nuclear reactor
designs are coming along and I think
that those will become much more popular
than people think right now also the
price of solar power is declining and if
the rate continues as it is in less than
ten years will be cheaper than natural
gas to produce electricity using solar
power but the other thing on adaptation
if I may is is that of course there's
already baked into the cake that we're
going to get warmer sea level rise a
little bit more and so forth so what
we'll have to do is do is what do as we
as humans have always done adapt to it
and we'll have air conditioning for our
homes crops will different crops will be
plant in different areas that kind of
thing but human beings will have a
century to it after this kind of thing
talk about the decline in the cost of
solar power where did that come from
that's an interesting question
there's something called Swanson's law
and it's kind of like Moore's law but
it's slightly different swans as well
basically says every time you double the
capacity of producing solar panels the
price goes down 20% what happened is
that the Germans decided that they were
going to subsidize into existence a huge
solar energy production system and they
did do that and the Chinese said fine we
will now supply the solar panels too so
basically the Germans taxpayers and the
Chinese businessmen or have created a
eco system an industrial eco system that
is dramatically lowering the price of
solar power
probably over what it would otherwise be
well you know your book your work in
general is always highly optimistic I
mean it's technically rigorous and it's
serious but it's optimistic in and the
the topics that you covered and normally
are like you know the last or the
strongest word out of fear mongers and
hysterics about the end of the world is
already underway how do you sell an
optimistic vision of a technologically
innovative and kind of kind to humans
future let me start out with a different
story about that is I had another book
earlier on on environmental issues
called eco scam that came out in the
early 90s and my editor at the time said
when we were citing a contract Ron I
just want to tell you we're gonna make
some money off of this book but if you
had brought me a book that said the
world was coming to an end I could have
made you a rich man do themselves as
you've noted but I think that optimism
can also sell in the sense that people
will eventually as I did will wake up
and look around and see that the world
is a lot better than the prognosticators
pretended it was going to be you will
always have people selling doom if it's
lucrative it makes you sound serious but
they will be proved wrong well and
hopefully you your editor will be proved
wrong in the end of doom well change a
lot of people's minds and make you a
rich man
finally you can come to my Caribbean
house well well we'll make a date for
that so I want to thank you we've been
talking with Ron Bailey he's the author
of the end of doom a positive look at
how the future is gonna be pretty damn
great Ron thanks for talking to us thank
you for having me for raisin TV I'm Nick
Gillespie